Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Emma Gon
¿Qué tiene que ver la Revolución Francesa
con el momento en que la NASA
estrelló accidentalmente
un orbitador de $ 200 millones
en la superficie de Marte?
En realidad, todo.
El accidente ocurrió debido a un error
en la conversión entre
dos sistemas de medición,
las unidades tradicionales de EE. UU.
y su S.I., o métrico, equivalente.
Y ¿cuál es la conexión
con la Revolución Francesa?
Vamos a explicarla.
Durante la mayor parte
de la historia humana,
unidades como el peso de un grano o
el largo de una mano no fueron exactas
y variaban de un lugar a otro.
Y distintas regiones no solo
utilizaban distintas mediciones,
tenían sistemas numéricos
completamente diferentes también.
A finales de la Edad Media,
el sistema decimal hindú-arábico
reemplazó mayormente los números
romanos y las fracciones de Europa,
pero los esfuerzos de
eruditos como John Wilkins
de promover medidas estándares basadas
en los decimales tuvieron menos éxito.
Con un cuarto de millón de
diferentes unidades solo en Francia,
cualquier cambio generalizado
requería una alteración masiva.
Y en 1789, vino esa alteración.
Los líderes de la Revolución francesa
no solo derrocaron a la monarquía,
sino que buscaron transformar
por completo la sociedad
de acuerdo con los principios
racionales de la Ilustración.
Cuando el nuevo gobierno asumió el poder,
la Academia de Ciencias convocó
a reformar el sistema de medición.
Las antiguas normas basadas en la
autoridad arbitraria o tradiciones locales
se sustituyeron por
relaciones matemáticas y naturales.
Por ejemplo, el metro,
de la palabra griega medir,
se definió como 1 / 10 000 000 parte
entre el ecuador y el polo norte.
Y el nuevo sistema métrico era,
en palabras del Marqués de Condorcet,
"Para todas las personas,
de todos los tiempos".
La estandarización de las medidas
tenía ventajas políticas
para los revolucionarios también.
Los nobles ya no podían
manipular las unidades locales
para extraer más alquiler a los plebeyos,
mientras que el gobierno podía recaudar
impuestos de manera más eficiente.
Y el cambio a un nuevo calendario
republicano con semanas de diez días
reducía el poder de la Iglesia mediante
la eliminación de los domingos.
La adopción de este nuevo
sistema no fue fácil.
De hecho, fue un poco un desastre.
Al principio, la gente utilizaba las
nuevas unidades junto a las antiguas,
y el calendario republicano
fue finalmente abandonado.
Cuando Napoleón Bonaparte tomó el poder,
permitió a las pequeñas empresas
utilizar mediciones tradicionales
redefinidas en términos métricos.
Pero el sistema métrico
se mantuvo estándar para uso formal,
y se extendió por todo el continente,
a lo largo de las fronteras de Francia.
Mientras que el imperio
de Napoleón duró ocho años,
su legado duró mucho más tiempo.
Algunos países europeos volvieron a
mediciones viejas al independizarse.
Otras se dieron cuenta
del valor de la normalización
en una época de comercio internacional.
Después que Portugal y Holanda pasaron
al sistema métrico voluntariamente,
otras naciones las siguieron,
con imperios coloniales que difundieron
el sistema por todo el mundo.
Como principal rival de Francia,
Gran Bretaña había resistido
las ideas revolucionarias
y conservado sus unidades tradicionales.
Aun así, durante los siguientes dos siglos
el Imperio Británico lentamente cambió,
primero aprobando el sistema métrico
como alternativa opcional
para después hacerlo gradualmente oficial.
Sin embargo, este cambio no llegó
a tiempo a las trece antiguas colonias
que ya habían logrado su independencia.
Los EE. UU. mantuvo las unidades
inglesas de su pasado colonial
y hoy en día sigue siendo
uno de los tres países
que no han abrazado completamente
el sistema métrico decimal.
A pesar de las iniciativas constantes
de conversión al sistema métrico,
muchos estadounidenses consideran
a los pies y las libras más intuitivas.
E irónicamente, algunos consideran
el sistema métrico revolucionario
como símbolo de la conformidad global.
Sin embargo, el sistema métrico se utiliza
casi universalmente en ciencia y medicina,
y continúa evolucionando de acuerdo
a sus principios originales.
Por mucho tiempo,
las unidades estándar en realidad estaban
definidas por cuidados prototipos físicos.
Pero gracias a la mejora
de la tecnología y la precisión,
estos objetos con acceso limitado
y de longevidad no fiable
ahora están siendo reemplazados con
normas basadas en constantes universales,
como la velocidad de la luz.
Las mediciones consistentes son una parte
tan integral de nuestra vida cotidiana
que es difícil apreciar el enorme logro
que ha sido para la humanidad.
Y del mismo modo que surgió
de una revolución política,
el sistema métrico sigue siendo crucial
para las revoluciones
científicas venideras.